يُزعم أن ليندسي شيفر البالغة من العمر 36 عامًا من
توماسفيل استأجرت قاتلًا مأجورًا
لقتل زوجها المنفصل عنها روبرت شيفر
على الرغم من أن هذه كانت محاولة فاشلة.
ليندساي الآن خلف القضبان بينما تنتظر
المحاكمة، وفقًا
لأخبار محكمة باهاما، لا يزال هناك العديد من صور
الرعشات في  أخبرني العديد من الأشخاص الذين تحدثت معهم اليوم في جزر البهاما على
صفحات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بـ Lindsay
أنهم
صُدموا بحدوث شيء
كهذا في مجتمعهم،
ويقولون الآن إنهم يولون اهتمامًا وثيقًا لما يحيط
بهم، وقد
صُدم أحد المقيمين في المجتمع عندما سمع  الأخبار لأن اسم
Lindsay shiver بدا مألوفًا بالنسبة له،
وهذا ما جعلنا نرغب في الذهاب إلى
أبعد من ذلك قليلاً والحفر في Little Deeper Bohemian.
نوع من العروض التي
يقوم فيها الأشخاص اليائسون في بعض الأحيان
بأشياء يائسة، إنه مجرد أشخاص حزينين لا يضطرون
إلى الذهاب إلى هذا الحد على الإطلاق ولا أحد يستحق
أيًا من ذلك، سنستمر في متابعة
القصة عندما نحصل على مزيد من التفاصيل فالون
هوارد WALB News 10 أخبار مسقط رأسك
مصدر